Only two of these are true. All real numbers are complex and all imaginary
numbers are complex. Let's look at our diagram. We can see that the complex
number rectangle contains all of the other rectangles inside it. So that means
that every rectangle that's inside the complex number rectangle Contains numbers
all of which are complex numbers. Since the imaginary numbers and the real
numbers are all inside of the complex numbers they are all complex. However the
complex number rectangle is not contained inside any of these other rectangles.
All of those categories are subsets of it. So there is no other category that we
can group all complex numbers into on this diagram. Since the real numbers and
the imaginary numbers are completely separate rectangles, they are separate
groups. Neither one is a subset of the other.